foreign
[Music]
our studio connect and our shiny we're
going to serve you a three-course meal
today on how we automated our data
processing error logging and uh
alerts
so it's time to meet the chefs my name
is Colby parish and I'm an informatics
specialist at the California Department
of Public Health I'm working there
through uscsf
hi my name is Andy Pham I'm also working
at the California Department of Public
Health also for UCSF
so this talk was inspired by a real life
event it was early 2020 and Andy and I
were working at the California
Department of Public Health
within a small informatics section
and shortly after that the covid-19
response began in our small section was
picked up and put onto covid-19 response
where we remain today
one of our main charges was to prop up
data pipelines and products to help
inform the response efforts
and automation was a strategy our team
utilized early on to help us be able to
maintain the scripts that we were
responsible for while continuing to
develop based on the emerging needs
but as the number of scripts that we
were responsible for grew and grew and
grew Sometimes some months it felt like
they doubled or tripled we quickly
realized the automation alone wasn't
enough
um to remain responsive should anything
go wrong so a group of us got together
and started tossing around ideas on how
we could Implement additional strategies
to be responsive quickly should anything
go wrong with any of our Scripts
and some of the strategies that we came
up with were automated air data
processing logging and alerts
as well as a process monitoring app
so today that three-course meal that
we're going to serve you starts with an
appetizer of how we automated our data
processing followed by a main course on
air alerts and logging and for those
shiny lovers we're going to give you a
taste of shiny in the form of a process
monitoring app at the end
so the way that we automated our data
processing was through a combination of
our markdown and rstudio connect
we chose the import from git option
that's available on our studio connect
and I'll tell you a little bit about why
we chose that option but it was really
easy to use because we store our code
and get repositories and essentially
what we needed to do was store a code
where we were already storing it add
make sure we had a manifest.json file
grab that get URL go to rstudio connect
click on the content section click a
publish button and then in a few steps
we were able to paste that URL that get
URL
into the screen and click a couple
additional buttons deploy our content
and we had our automated Scripts
but one of the things that we really
liked about this import from git option
was that it not only helped us automate
our scripts but it helped us automate
our pipelines and that's because with
the check of a button we were able to
say anytime we make a change to our git
repository have that code change Auto
flow to that published content
so great now we have automation but
imagine one of those many automated
scripts results in an error
how are you going to see what Eric heard
and where
doing that can kind of be like finding a
single noodle in a giant bowl of messy
spaghetti just a little bit frustrating
but air alerts and logging are there to
help
the way that we implemented that was
through a combination of our markdown
blastula log it and rstudio connect
so the process was really similar for us
um
to the way that we automated our data
processing except we added in a few
additional layers and those layers were
logging email alert logic and an error
report template and for us that was in
the form of an R markdown document which
added some structure to those email
alerts
so we started by calling the logit
package and we chose the login package
because it made it really easy to create
custom error messages
as well as add in additional custom
fields to the the log messages
and then we set up our log pass and this
helped specify where we wanted the
resulting log files to be written to
and then we had to strategically place
the login function calls throughout our
script
and what we did is we put a logic call
at the start of each our markdown chunk
upon air and we use the try catch
function to do this I'll show you an
example in just a moment and then at the
end of each our markdown chunk
it was really important for us to within
our markdown scripts to name each chunk
with a unique name because we then
passed that information back to the the
log
so this is an example of a logic call
upon error using the track hatch
function and you see in the event of an
error we are calling log it
it was pretty easy to use this specific
example is a message an error message
type so that's that first parameter
there and then the next is a custom
error message that we created used using
a paste function so we essentially can
put any text that we want and then pass
that error message to that paste
function and then the other fields that
were custom that we found really helpful
to help us pinpoint exactly where any
issues were occurring was the script
name the the chunk name so the the
section of code within a specific script
and then we also like to allow attempt
numbers because sometimes there are
chunks of code that will retry in the
event of an error and then version was
another field that we like to log
because it helped us determine if the
error occurred in a production or a
development pipeline
so the resulting log file looks a little
something like this you can see that we
chose to Output a log file by day
and that was helpful because we have a
lot of scripts and they're running on a
regular basis and we
have a lot of log entries so this helped
us be able to quickly just kind of
organize things by day
if you were to open up that file it
would look a little something like this
it is a json-based format so it does
need to be parsed and he's going to
cover how we did that later on in the
talk
um but you'll notice that the fields
that are logged are similar to what you
saw in that login function call so that
first one there is an error message and
it's a log level type of error you could
also log things like informational
messages or Warnings as well and then
the next field there is a custom error
message and if we were to look at the
rest of the log file we'd find those
additional custom Fields like script
name chunk name and version
so now that we have our log set up and
our logging is happening I'm going to
cover a little bit about how we
implemented air alerts and it was
relatively easy to use do by just adding
a little extra code at the end of each
our map our markdown chunk outside of
the try catch function
and in the event of an error we
essentially use blastula to send out an
email and so that highlighted code there
shows the section of code that will
actually render the email using a
specified error report template that's
the error underscore report.rmd I'll
show you what that looks like in the
next slide and once that's rendered then
blastula then blasts it out to the
viewers and collaborators that you
specify when you set up the automation
all right so this is a screenshot of the
our markdown error report template that
we use we like to keep it really simple
and just include the information that we
find uh helpful to pinpoint exactly
where any issues occurred so that
includes version again then for us that
means development versus production the
script name the chunk name so exactly
where that error occurred within a
script the error itself and then we also
like to include a path to the full log
file just in case we want to look at the
history there
so putting this all together how this
works is we have our script published on
our studio connect and it's on the
schedule and it's running on a regular
basis we have our login integrated into
the script we have that error Alert
Logic integrated in the event and event
error um connect will essentially blast
use blasted and send out an email to the
specified viewers and collaborators
that error email follows the template
that I showed you earlier and looks a
little something like this this is just
a dummy error email that we set up but
you see here the version is our Dev
pipeline you see the script name the
chunk name the error itself and then we
also have a spot for the log path there
so I'm going to turn the floor over to
Andy to cover how we took those log
files that were in Json base format and
turned them into something a little more
digestible
all right thank you Colby so now you
have your automated processes set up and
you have your email alerts for error
logging now let's say we get an email
saying that there's an error the next
step is to troubleshoot right
however errors rarely occur in isolation
in order to fix an error efficiently and
to prevent it from occurring again in
future States you want to be able to
find if this error is occurring in your
development and production environment
as this is an error occurred multiple
times throughout your processes
and so before the process monitoring app
what we would have to do
is we have to go through the error and
process logs and as Chloe mentioned
before these are in Json format and so
and there's probably hundreds to
thousands of lines of this so you'd be
pretty much abusing your control F to
try to find what errors uh occur and
where it occurred and that's also not to
mention
that since we're logging almost every
day we'd have to go through all these
files to see if there's like some kind
of historic uh pattern coming on from
these errors
and so going through all this I would
have created to sort of trying to eat a
melting ice cream sundae everything's
mixed together uh different ice cream
flavors are mixing and you might you're
you're tasting like two three different
flavors and you're not sure if you like
it or not it's very interesting however
our approach was to season in some art
our magic and make a more beautiful ice
cream sundae where all the components
are easily seeable and you can get to
where you need to be quickly and
efficiently
and so we did this with this was our
process for our process monitoring app
we took a bunch of messy logs
applied some login our shiny poly data
tables any R visualization packages
and turned it into a dashboard where we
can view both how our processes were
doing and the errors we got within one
single dashboard
however we first needed to be able to
read all of these logs into something
that was R readable
fortunately for us
log it provides this function already
there is a function called read
underscore logs where if you pass the
path of your error file it'll read in
that error file and return in our data
table that's easily filtered so now we
could filter based on if we wanted to
find an error and then by which specific
process and then with within a specific
time frame so this is very useful for
putting up the dashboard initially
and so we fed this data into a data
table call and built error data tables
where we could view all of our error
data errors in relation to each other
when they occurred and if they occurred
within any other processes
We additionally fit our process logs
into another data table and because we
had set up our login calls within the HR
markdown Chunk we can now see how long
each our markdown chunk took within the
process and be able to identify any
bottlenecks as needed
what we also did was we also fed some of
the process log data into
plotly and so we created this graph
where we could easily be able to see how
our processes were doing in relation to
each other and in relation to our
development and production environments
we could also see if any processes were
running much much longer than we
expected so that we can get in there and
fix it before anything
broke
and so we took all of these different
pieces the error data tables the graphs
and we put it all into a use our shiny
to put it all into a dashboard and so
now we could get what we where we needed
to be really quickly and be able to see
our both of our development and
production errors and processes in one
setting
and so the outcome of this is that we
had all of our error viewing
troubleshooting and process monitoring
in one place and we could get to where
we need to be quickly
in addition because of shine our shiny's
sort of user-friendly interface
we could have new users on our team be
able to dive into being able to fix our
errors without having to know the
intricacies of our Mr training system
because we already had an interface
built over that layer
and so new new hires to our team could
also start contributing to this process
monitoring app again without having to
know too much or spend too much time
learning about how our error logging
system works
and so errors happen we're all human
these are we hope these tools that we
and recipe that we have made available
to you today help you be able to create
a full three-course air friendly meal
that's easily digestible and worthy of
phrase
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]